PROFESSOR: Partial
orders are another way
to talk about digraphs
and they offer to us
an interesting
lesson in the idea
of axiomatizing a
mathematical structure
and mathematical ideas.
So let's begin by discussing
some of the properties
that we're going to use to
axiomatize partial orders
and digraphs.
So if we think about
walks in a digraph,
the basic property of walks is
that if you have a walk from u
to v and you have
a walk from v to w,
then you put the
two walks together
and you wind up with
a walk from u to w.
Expressed in terms of the
positive walk relation
in G, what this is saying is
that if u G plus v and v G
plus w, then u G plus w.
And that abstract
property-- which
I'm highlighting with
the magenta box--
when you apply it to
an arbitrary relation
is called a
transitivity property.
So a relation R on
a set-- that is,
R is relating-- the
domain and co-domain of R
are the same-- is that u R
v and v R w implies u R w.
And a relation that
has that property
is said to be transitive.
And, of course,
what we've just seen
is the positive path relation
of any graph G is transitive.
Another way to say
transitivity is
to read u R v as saying
there's an edge from u to v.
And what this says is that if
there's an edge from u to v
and an edge from v to w,
there's an edge from u to w.
Or, in other words, if
there's a path of length 2,
there's a path of length 1.
And then by easy
induction it follows
that if there's a
path of any length
between-- of any positive
lengths between two vertices,
then in fact there's
a path of length 1.
That is, an edge between them.
OK, so the basic theorem
that we have to begin with
is what is
transitivity capturing
as a property of a relation.
And a relation R
is transitive if
and only if, in fact, R is
equal to the positive walk
relation for some digraph
G. The proof of this
is basically trivial
because you could
let the relation
R be the digraph
that it's the positive
path relation of.
If we look now at
directed acyclic graphs,
then what we have is that
if there's a positive length
path from a vertex
u to a vertex v,
then since there's no cycles
in a directed acyclic graph,
there can't be a path
back from v to u,
and that property
is called asymmetry.
So D plus, which is the
positive path relation, in a DAG
has this asymmetry property.
Namely, if u can get to v by a
positive length path and it's
not possible for v to get back
to u by a positive length path.
So, abstracted, u R
v implies not v R u.
That's the asymmetry property
of an arbitrary relation R.
And by definition of acyclic,
D plus is asymmetric in a graph
without cycles.
OK.
A strict partial order
is simply a relation
that has these two
properties of being
transitive and asymmetric.
And some examples of
strict partial orders
are the proper
containment relation
on sets, which we've
previously commented
can be viewed as a DAG, but
now it satisfies transitivity.
And the fact that if one set's
properly contained in another,
the second one can't be
properly contained in the first
because proper means you
have something extra.
The indirect prerequisite
relation on MIT subjects
would be another example
of a strict prerequisite.
If I'm a prerequisite
of you, you
can't be a prerequisite of me.
And finally, the less than
relation on real numbers.
These are all examples
of strict partial orders.
And putting together
the previous reasoning,
what we can say is
that a relation R
is a strict partial
order if and only
if R is the positive path
relation for some DAG, D.
So the axioms that define
strict partial order,
namely transitivity
and asymmetry,
can be said to
abstractly capture
the property of a relation
that it comes from a DAG.
Another important
property of partial orders
is the idea of being
path-total, or linear
as some authors call it.
And the simple
definition of path-total
is that given any
two elements, one
is going to be bigger than
the other with respect
to the relation.
Most familiar example of that
would be the less than relation
of a less than or equal
to relational on the reals
given any two distinct
real numbers-- x and y.
Either x is less than
y or y is less than x.
And we take that
property for granted.
Now, the formal
definition then is simply
that if x is not equal to y,
then either x R y or y R x,
and relation R that has that
property is called path-total.
Another way to say
it is that there
are no incomparable
elements under R.
And I've, again, highlighted
with a magenta box
this property, which is
called path-totality.
Another way to say
that a path-total is
that the whole order
looks like a chain.
If you give me a
bunch of elements,
there's going to have to
be a biggest one and then
a next biggest one and so
on, assuming you've given me
any finite set of elements.
So the basic example,
again, of path-total
would be number
properties of bigger than.
And a basic example of something
that would typically not
be path-total would
be, let's say,
subset containment where
you can perfectly well have
two sets, neither of which
is contained in the other.
So a weak partial order
is a small variation
of a strict partial order.
That is another
familiar concept where
we take the strict
property, which
guarantees that nothing's
related to itself,
and we relax it.
So a strict partial
order is just
like a weak partial order
except that the condition
that there's no positive
length path between an element
in itself is relaxed.
So, in fact, it's
not only relaxed,
but it's completely denied.
In a weak partial order, we
insist that every element
is related to itself.
An example of that would be the
less than or equal to relation.
Sorry, the improper
containment relation.
The ordinary subset
relation on sets
where now a is a subset
with a bar under it.
a is just a subset
of a, not necessarily
a strict subset
or a proper subset
means that, in fact,
a is a subset of a.
And then less than or equal,
and you put the little bar
under the less than sign to
indicate that equality is also
a possibility, you get
a weak partial order
on the real numbers.
So the property that
distinguishes the weak
from the strict is this
property of reflexivity.
A relation R on a
set is reflexive
if every element is
related to itself,
if and only if a R a for all
little a in the domain capital
A. And what we can
observe immediately
is that the path of the walk
relation-- G star-- which
includes walks of
length zero is reflexive
because, by definition,
there is a length zero
walk from any vertex to itself.
So if you're going
to play with axioms,
then you can
reformulate asymmetry--
the idea of asymmetry
except for elements
being related to themselves.
It's called
antisymmetry, and it says
that a relation R
is antisymmetric if
and only if it's asymmetric
except for the a R a case.
And more precisely,
the difference
between asymmetry
and antisymmetry
is that in asymmetry a
R a is never allowed,
and in antisymmetry a
R a is a possibility.
It's not disallowed.
So an antisymmetric relation
on R stated abstractly
is that u R v implies not
v R u for u not equal to v.
So the first line is exactly
the statement of asymmetry,
and then I add this
proviso that it only
has to hold when the u
and the v are not equal.
That's the formal way
of saying antisymmetry
is the same as asymmetry
except for a R a.
And the walk relation
in a digraph,
which includes length zero
walks, is antisymmetric.
So weak partial
orders-- just what
you get when you put
these things together--
weak partial order is
transitive, antisymmetric,
and reflexive.
So in a weak partial order,
we insist that every element
be related to itself.
So there's a-- just
a quick remark.
Asymmetric implies
nothing's related to itself.
Reflexive implies everything
is related to itself.
And it's possible that
there be some graph
in which some
elements are related
to themselves and some not.
That would be something
that was neither
a strict nor a
weak partial order.
It would just be transitive
and antisymmetric.
Those don't come
up much and so we
don't bother to give them
a name or talk about them.
And, finally, the theorem that
summarizes up this whole story
is that R is a weak
partial order if and only
if R is equal to the walk
relation for some DAG,
including length zero walks.